my guy how you doing man I'm looking
forward to this man I'm looking forward
to it what's up man
how are you real pleasure what a
pleasure good to see man how you been
today real pleasure
hey man don't do what the [ __ ] I mean I
get it but you couldn't like covered up
underneath the jacket like hearty
feelings like that I'm in a bad mood now
Boyd I'm really in a bad [ __ ] mood
man I'm in a real bad mood yo yeah nice
to meet you man so what's going on man
what's good man what are you doing in
town oh just chris is putting meat steak
mm-hmm good number two just getting out
there I [ __ ] with you heaviest [ __ ] like
like I'm putting I think you guys know
I'm putting you on blatt like I'm I'm on
the record of who I think is next and
it's you because I have that like I know
my ear which is like I don't think I'm
anything like I don't even like to talk
to music people about music but I know
me and I know like I just know I you
know I don't know you like I don't know
how disciplined you are like like I
don't know you I'm excited to start to
get to know you but like if you stay
discipline and you [ __ ] actually work
and if you don't get a little taste of
success and think you made it and do
dumb like too many people like I don't
know you but I know your music is a
hundred percent foregone conclusion and
so you know that's what I think but you
know what I mean like the biggest
problem the biggest issue now is
actually where you're at now this is the
sneaky part I'm so fascinated by this
part where there's a little something it
feels like something right it's just
tricky I'm just now that I'm really
paying attention for the last year like
just like I've listened to more music
I'm paying attention more than I have
literally since like the sort like
nineteen ninety four or five like
seriously and it's so obvious you're
gonna win but it's also so obvious that
like everybody thinks like getting from
zero to where you are right now is the
hard work and it's the [ __ ] like it
gets much harder now to take it to that
next spot because it's frustrating
because when you got nothing or nobody's
paying attention it's just so
interesting
you guys agree hunger and it's confusing
right you get somebody that comes up to
you and go and that like it's big and
they're like yo I [ __ ] with you and
you're like oh [ __ ] like it's just
confusing like I'll tell you how it is
for me like on the business side like
when I'm on the cover of these different
magazines or when I did the Apple TV
show like you always think like this is
the thing okay oh when this happens
like I'm sure when you guys run a studio
like when this second project comes out
this is gonna be the [ __ ] fire that
takes it too though but then like like
it's the mentality of like when it
doesn't being even more hungry not
deflated I'm fascinated by that [ __ ]
[Music]
he's the best work but I just I'm in
like a studio
watch some interview and Gary's super
tight with Michael I don't know if that
was not the show but the other thing is
so this project rest for a second I know
I eat most briefly but they're both
extreme cut as you know and they want to
team up and like basically promote the
book promote the project on Spotify you
get free say something and then each
side like you know all these music some
motivational so don't give up like you
sign a book we do two three four
whatever and we just do some type of
contest just to help everyone have you
know cuz they're down to promote the
money so I think I think I think here's
how I think about that that's a good
idea
but what's even more exciting to me is
how obnoxiously authentic this
relationship is like like you know what
I mean like to me I would do that with
somebody who's got like four million
followers that like I don't even like to
mean [ __ ] like forget about my book like
I'm from I've been been promoting like
I'm gonna promote the [ __ ] out of it
like I'm gonna listen to it right twice
it and then decide what song I [ __ ] with
the motor you know like oh we put
together the playlist he literally text
me a screenshot of your song that yo bro
this one's on this week but boy does 89
to 94% of the playlist like I'll listen
one time to make sure nothing's weird I
may take something out he always tries
to give me a little love of my John rub
like throwback a song or two but then I
got to make sure that was like a song I
[ __ ] with but it's very rare for a new
artist for me to hit him up and be like
this has to go
I'm just so convinced about where you're
going gonna honestly on a very serious
no man I really really really think
you've got the absolute exact right
thing for what's about to happen I just
think you need to you know my big thing
is collaborations and volume like you
guys do you that's always my thing like
to me I just want you to do more [ __ ]
like you know like artists always like
it's always tricky with my advice to
artists because I want more volume and
artists can run like they don't want to
dilute it they want it to be like part
like I have empathy but I know it's
right because because
here's what people to understand with
volume they remember the hits they
forget the other [ __ ] you don't have the
potential to suck you understand that
right like like him I was like hey you
do you understand what I mean like if I
was like yo you have to put out a
hundred songs in a row your weakest one
of those hundred in my opinion isn't
gonna be weak enough to [ __ ] you up
and the upside of a hundred [ __ ]
at-bats I believe in that [ __ ] and then
collaborations like like [ __ ] I think I
was just listening to one of yours
[ __ ] we just now let me see this
would be great yep this is literally
literally what I'm listening to
yeah like right like this like as many
of those as possible I can't say it
enough man it's just how Muse like you
guys are in it and you know it better
than me I just know what humans do
that's why I'm gonna do my thing
it's just that bad people don't get it
it's just tomorrow song that changes
everything and and it's hard right
because you put so much into it's like
parenting you like raise this kid you
love um but then like something that
happens at school is a defining moment
and I had nothing to do with you other
than what how you set it up there's
someone you're so lucky that you're in
Atlanta there's something happened in
the studio every day I don't know that's
where I'm at
New York - its it's Atlanta 1 2 & 3 it's
not even music it's it's everything it's
literally culture it's such an craite so
I'm opening an office in Atlanta a
hundred percent in the next years 100% I
just I just want to be there like I'll
make up the reason for me to have an
office backwards I'm being serious it's
that important it's very serious you you
know what's most serious about it from
my perspective from an outsider's
perspective is all the different sounds
like it would be one thing if it was one
sound but the fact that you run the
gamut of savage to me goes to Russ to
you know just all of it it's soda it
really is subtle nuances that I think it
makes it very important the fact that
that can all coexist what else can i
what can we help you with so obviously
the project right like you guys
obviously want that to be as successful
as possible I really you know we can do
for you uh I got idea um
d-roc you know we're gonna do I wanna
we're gonna hit up like fifty to a
hundred vloggers you're up can you give
me a favor say hello to everybody
do you rock Gunnar's project comes out
next week seconds yeah two weeks I want
to when he when I drop and they've got
it already like I wanna hit up like
fifty to a hundred of our vlogging
friends and tell him that we really [ __ ]
with him and we it would mean a lot to
us if they used some sample of some song
in their content you want to have
somebody like Alex or whatever put
together list let's get like 15 block
like cuz that's how she could go
okay thanks T rubbish Goods and they
tagged you in that [ __ ] goes crazy it
just get it listens man just getting
people to hear it
what's a radio it's a [ __ ] thing that
got people right yo one thing I would
ask you what got you on camera and stuff
is like your song is like don't give up
and phase and everything like what's the
more like what you thinking about when
you're writing a song man cuz I've
watched some interviews that you've been
doing and that's just something I think
people want to know all this music is so
personal and is some motivational I get
that's why I like to I like a room I
like rust because he's competitive and
chip-on-the-shoulder
like it's all based on versions of my
own personality you perform that you're
talking truth and you're not scared to
go into territories that don't look the
part that's it nah yeah like I'm just
being like third person mm-hmm I got a
song change
you talk to that nobody that's what my
cell you know it's fun you know it's
funny about that
Mike one of my favorite things I say
ever I say a lot of [ __ ] is uh money
doesn't change you it just exposes you I
believe in that [ __ ] so much you are who
you are you know what my back should one
of my buddies
he lives in Alpharetta one of my buddies
from college moved to Atlanta right from
the get like I went to the 99 Super Bowl
um kind of trouble at the Gold Club that
night
oh they shot that [ __ ] gangster ass
place down thank God anyway he hit me up
the other day and he was like man I just
wish all these cuz and he's like these
are the kids he's the one that
introduced me to Scarface and ghetto
boys like these are my hood friends this
is where I got any of it from he's like
I just wit it was crazy was so emotional
for me like he was like I wish people
really knew how you didn't change you
know it was really cool because it just
doesn't change you it doesn't [ __ ]
exposes the [ __ ] out of you first time
come I can
[Laughter]
because it's so ruined down here because
the stuff that's getting passed down
there is just the worst of the worst so
they just New Yorkers don't know the
difference they just know that you pass
it out and then like and the guys like
give me my 20 bucks and like they
believe you because that's not the move
right no New York's very simple hey free
Sydney where's my 20 bucks it's some
gangster [ __ ] man that's Times Square
man that's the truth how you gonna do me
like that give me my 20 bucks yeah it's
no joke yeah man he's so much talent
right he's the best good good good he's
so talented I think he's gonna be a
super like super producer he's just like
now that I'm like now that I've been
really like I've been spending a lot of
time DMing with like Sonny digital and
Metro boomin and like like I'm not like
I said this to crit like I'm not like a
real music guide the reason I [ __ ] with
you is what you're saying like like I
like the story you know I like that
you're going to places that I think are
vulnerable and truth cuz that guy will
macro will always win that's what people
always thin about POC and Biggie go go
like actually go back and listen to
pocket
they were talking about like you guys
are youngsters like you don't understand
like Brenda's got a baby like that was a
that was ridiculous like that was [ __ ]
like like like biggie
like and just like storytelling right
like Biggie's funny like I got a story
to tell you was funny like it's that was
different this was when hip-hop was like
I'm hardcore like I'm tough and you're
not simple binary there was no other
story so they're vulnerable don't get
why they broke out for a million reasons
but nobody I mean I watch every
documentary I read everything and I'm
waiting for somebody to say those guys
broke out they say storytellers they'll
compare them to K R Us one things like
that's fine it's the vulnerability wait
that's all I know
you're like wow really no no no I'm
saying yeah you're sitting next to them
I've been in a room or maybe not even
seen each other face to face but I still
feel like I know you from your music
because of her what you say but you put
me in a world like that makes people
Tony I hope you got it oh my man my man
my man you will be a big big big [ __ ]
star if you stay focused like a big one
good I'm being I know it's like a
flattering just like I smile when people
say like I think you'll be a big star
you need to really think and focus you
you need to focus man like you need to
like my advice go in a cocoon meaning
like go out do live like but like
mentally being a cook like anything that
veers you from completely dominating be
out so you can go out every night but
don't get caught up in anything that
weird like you need to be obsessed cuz
gifts are [ __ ] rare man listen I've
been listening to a lot of stuff you
guys have been watching the stuff you
guys have heard a lot of these
interviews or been in the room you have
I don't feel like this about 99% of
people I've been meeting with I'm 99 I'm
telling you I bet
[Laughter]
I gotta go I really believe man let's
take a quick photo cuz I gotta bounce
I hate they gotta bounce I wish I could
stay here for an hour but we'll get
together again I'm glad you guys came
through I cook with a pair for name
yeah but LeBeau to keep erotic same i
they got up and out
you